je suis pour
nous avons un très grand herbier de
france et on a un très gros aviez du
loiret qui font à peu près les mêmes
tailles
la priorité c'est de décider quels sont
les collections le plus important à
travailler en ce moment
[Musique]
pendant les travaux du muséum les
équipes travaillent sans relâche à
l'inventaire des collections notamment
sur celui du fonds botanique constitué
des ouvrages anciens et de 42000
planches de plantes des herbiers dont
certains datent de près de 200 ans
c'est toujours intéressé les hommes de
connaître les plantes qui les entoure et
c'est lé rebord isation était une
activité scientifique très répandue non
seulement chez les vrais scientifiques
mais aussi chez les amateurs éclairés et
chez tout un chacun en fait pratiquement
dans toutes les familles il y avait au
moins un herbier pour connaître les
fleurs qui via les plantes qui poussent
autour de nous on a un très gros travail
de numérisation à faire pour que les
gens puissent se consulter en fait les
planches dervier plus facilement sur un
ordinateur
[Musique]
vladimir est spécialisée en biologie
tropicale
fraîchement arrivé au muséum il passe
son temps dans les réserves pour dresser
l'histoire des collections botaniques
je
il a redécouvert tout récemment un
herbier exceptionnel celui de
l'orléanais jacques martial pelletier
sont les membres de la société royale
des sciences
[Musique]
moi avec la recherche que j'ai fait je
me suis rendu compte que l'été ce sont
les il a découvert une plante qui
s'appelle patchouli qui a connu comme
patchouli c'est pas beau gosse lemon
patchouli pour la première fois en
europe qui a décrit pas reculer comme
une nouvelle plante une nouvelle espèce
pour la science comment exposer une
planche de patchouli au grand public
montrer des graines des végétaux sur ces
questions les scénographes du futur
musée aux morlanais bien avancé nous
allons exposer des planches dessinées et
nous allons aussi est exposé des
spécimens sécher entre deux plaques de
verre des planches derbier plus moderne
et puis surtout on va exposer des
plantes vivantes dans notre serre en
double peau que nous aurons façade dans
cette serre végétal ventilée
naturellement les plantes issues de la
biodiversité ligérienne trouveront toute
leur place comme les sauvages de nos
rues ces petites plantes qui poussent
entre deux pierres